on n'a cessé de me reprocher tout les
choses qui ont fait le succès du pacte
des loups par exemple le nombre de gens
qui m'ont reproché le plan sur monica
bellucci nuit qui devient une montagne
voilà qui se couvre de neige et qu'il ya
une montagne ce plan c'est le plan donc
tout le monde me parle quand je voyage
torino tous les gens me parlent de
larmes de vincent cassel quand je voyage
autour du monde en corée et m'ont parlé
et nous et à quelle idée extraordinaire
c'est dire que en france on est vraiment
on a vraiment un parapluie ouvert dans
le cul
[Musique]
il n'y a jamais eu de copie hd de ce
film le stade intermédiaire qu'a connu à
peu près tous les films ce film n'a
jamais connu on est parti d'une copie sd
standard à et passe directement aux
quatre cas donc les gens vont avoir une
surprise et en plus on a décidé de
refaire le mixage à l'identique
d'ailleurs comme l'image mais en dolby
apos donc tout ça ça en fait un objet
aujourd'hui très très très forte mais
évidemment il fallait pour ça avoir un
vrai financement parce que
restauration comme ça coûte beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher qu'une simple
restauration à partir d'éléments
standard là on est on a conduit une
rolls royce et et quand justement on
retravaille comme ça son oeuvre comme ça
avait un temps plus tard est ce qu on a
pas cette envie de dire ah ça je leur
toucherait j'ai envie de leur faire et
c'est celle de george lucas cela fait
externe c'est un minable mais même en
mai on attendait ce qu'on la connaît en
fait on vit quelque part alors on se
retient de normand énorme à moi non
alors pour une raison simple d'abord je
suis cinéphile et et je dirais presque
je suis plus cinéphile que cinéaste
c'est à dire que pour moi la
préservation des films et la façon dont
on regarde les films la façon dont le
public film finalement existe dans
l'oeil du public et surtout l'oeil de
ses admirateurs avant avant d'être
l'oeuvre de quelqu'un pour moi ça a du
sens c'est une forme de philosophie
chaque mois je pense que à part la pac à
partir du moment où un film sort surtout
quand il a du succès il appartient aux
gens il n'appartient plus à moi moi je
suis le dépositaire de l'intégrité du
film de l'histoire qui se sont déroulées
pour arriver à faire ce film je le
connais ce film parfaitement mais le
film ne m'appartient plus il appartient
aux gens maintenant donc je vois pas
pourquoi j'irais changer quoi que ce
soit dans le film que les gens ont aimé
et puis d'autre part pourquoi vouloir
essayer de rajeunir un film qui à mon
sens était en avance déjà sur son temps
et aujourd'hui quand je dis ça c'est pas
par flagornerie c'est à dire que on sait
tous que le la proposition de cinéma du
pacte des loups s'est finalement
concrétisé c'est d'ailleurs l'idée d'un
cinéma très métissé où on invite
beaucoup surtout les influences
asiatiques à l'intérieur du cinéma
occidental voit bien que ça s'est passé
finalement c'est arrivé donc le film
était quelque part en avance donc pour
voir pourquoi essayer de rajeunir un
film qui était quand même déjà en avance
sur son temps de jeu je vois pas ça
n'aurait aucun sens quand j'ai attaqué
la restauration du pacte des loups j'ai
fait projeter à l'équipe qui était
d'ailleurs l'équipe d'origine du film le
moteur d'origine les mixeurs d'origine
etc
je l'aurais prophéte on a fait une
projection d'une copie standard à peu
près potable du film parce que le film a
quand même 20 ans dont on a tous regardé
et à la fin de la projection j'ai dit
voilà on fait ça on ne fait pas autre
chose c'est le film qu'on fait on va pas
raccourcir des plantes on va pas changer
de choses on va simplement transposé à
l'identique ce film sur un support qui
évidemment beaucoup plus performant en
termes de détails de textures évidemment
à travers un système sonore
absolument incroyable donc le film a
gagné en puissance et en muscles mais
c'est le même film c'est le même film il
était hors de question d'aller changer
quoi que ce soit bien sûr que si je
faisais le film aujourd'hui je le ferai
pas de la même façon il y aurait
certainement moins de plans on va dire
les choses comme ça mais ce film
représente un moment qui je me rappelle
quand je quand j'ai fait le pacte des
loups j'étais très impressionné par the
rock de michael bay enfin un film qui
m'avait soufflé au niveau technique etc
et je me rappelle chaque année les gens
m'ont parlé je disais avec avec le pacte
des loups on va faire le the rope du
film en costumes et
donc c'était l'idée de base je vois pas
pourquoi je vais je vais changer ça ah
les gens aujourd'hui peuvent dire oui
finalement le pacte des loups c'était
une espèce de maille de films de à la
michael b et c oui j'ai par franchise je
le dis c'est vrai c'était aussi un film
sur une influence du daim et des moyens
corps de michael mann qui est très
certainement un bien plus beaux films
que the rock mais
la façon dont le film a été découpé la
façon dont le film a été montée était
très influencé par par le montage demain
lb sur the rock donc je vais pas changer
les choses c'est la vérité donc le film
doit garder cette vérité que ça plaise
aux seins ou que ça déplaise aux
personnes c'est comme ça moyer je vois
des films faits dans les années 30 des
fois je trouve il ya des choses qui sont
super bien vu puis des fois je dis ça
c'est quand même un peu datés c'est aux
gens de juger c'est au spectateur jugé
comme on dit en anglais et of the
beholder les choses appartiennent à
l'oeil de l'admirateur et il faut que
les choses restent comme ça donc du coup
au niveau des effets spéciaux quand j'ai
revu
la restauration de katia j'avais pas vu
le film de d'avant à l'époque et je me
suis posé avec la js qu'il a retouché
aux effets spéciaux alors c'est très
simple les effets spéciaux c'est pas que
j ai touché j'ai simplement pu étalonner
enfin les effets spéciaux à l'époque
quand on a essuyé un peu les plâtres de
cette nouvelle technique et l étalonnage
numérique mais les tonnages numérique
quand vous faites des étalonnages
d'éléments composites c'est à dire d'une
image dans lequel on a rajouté un
élément vous êtes obligés de faire des
cachets des contres cash et il fallait
chaque image que se cache bouge
c'était la pagaille aujourd'hui avec les
nouveaux moyens vous fixez un élément
est immédiatement l'ordinateur calcule
la position de cet élément d'image en
image ok voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'à l'époque on a fait l'étalonnage des
effets spéciaux à la va vite surtout
qu'ils sont arrivés très en retard on
les a inclus dans le film on n'a pas pu
les étalonner d'une manière performante
et voilà le film mais ce qui l'était etc
et aujourd'hui j'ai pu faire enfin un
étalonnage correcte des effets spéciaux
parce qu'ils donnent l'impression qu'ils
ont été retravaillés quelque part
travailler ils ont su rester et à mener
correctement
là on arrive bush et ses effets spéciaux
d'époque ils sont là et il passe
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui et fassent
beaucoup mieux simplement parce que par
exemple dans l'année dans la copie
standards du film la bête elle tirait
des fois un peu sur le verre où elle
tirer un peu sur le magenta et on
n'arrivait pas à rééquilibrer sa sur le
fond qui était généralement un fonds et
les règles des torches parce que la bête
apparaît massivement dans des scènes de
nuit et en fait maintenant la bête à la
couleur de la scène elle n'est plus une
espèce de mach a rajouté un peu verdâtre
ou un peu rouge voyage voilà chers que
maintenant mais on a en a on n'avait pas
refait les effets spéciaux mais
simplement j'ai les ai fait correctement
vous avez construit effectivement un
cinéma de genre qui n'existe plus
presque pas en france et je trouve ça
dommage qu'il n'y a pas eu ce déclic
français derrière on est quand même en
2001 il ya personne qui a pris la route
derrière et même vous j'ai envie de dire
les le cinéma français tels qu'ils les
faits tels qu'ils aient pensé c'est un
cinéma assez pépère on va dire le mot
pour pas être plus méchant c'est un
cinéma assez pépère des communes a su
qu'aux pêcheurs
mais c'est pas ce n'est pas la cas
pourquoi la comédie parce que la comédie
ça peut être fait simplement et ça peut
rapporter gros une fois sur dix et même
voir une fois sur romain ménard venir
moi ça peut rapporter gros et simplement
parce que le cinéma français fait par
des gens qui sont surtout des passes
plats qu'ils ont surtout des gens qui
font les allers retours entre la banque
le le cercle distributeurs et les
chaînes de tv après il prenne 20% au
passage et rentrer chez eux ils sont
contents tout va bien faire un film
comme le pacte des loups c'est beaucoup
de travail mais ça prend deux c'est
aussi cédé pas seulement des risques
c'est beaucoup de travail il faut il
faut se pointer à la montagne à 5 heures
du matin avec des animaux dressés des
loups
il faut habiller des tonnes de figurants
et faudrait les airs c'est ce qui fait
la magie ce sommet de semer les français
nés en france les gens veulent pas de ça
voilà on l'a fait autrefois mais on ne
fait plus on n'a pas envie on n'a pas
envie c'est trop c'est trop risqué mais
les films qui ont existé que ça soit par
exemple
le pacte des loups que ce soit la belle
et la bête qui sont des films en
français donc à gros budget ils ont
existé parce que derrière ces films il y
avait ce que j'appelle des modules c'est
à dire des gens qui sont pas exactement
des producteurs qui sont des gens des
supers financier avec une vision du
cinéma et dans le cas présent c'était
pierre lescure pour le pacte des loups
et c'était évidemment jérôme seydoux
pour la belle et la bête sont des gens
qui ont voulu ces films là pour des
raisons qui leur appartiennent
à partir du moment où des personnes
aussi puissante 10,1 disent je veux ce
film là le film se fait mais à plus et
donc il ya un producteur qui vient et
qui sur l'injonction du chef on va dire
va lancer le film mais c'est la volonté
et sert que
malheureusement en france on a très peu
de ce genre de super producteur de super
financiers on en a très peu et surtout
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas une vision
de ce qu'ils aimeraient voir au cinéma
ils ont pas ils n'ont pas de vision
artistique n'y a pas de vision
artistique pour faire un film comme
celui-là ça demande une énorme
préparation ça demande des repérages
très long ça demande surtout de
travailler des storyboards de faire des
artwork etc c'est à dire de bien tout
préparé à l'avancé et les gens ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent réunir les quelques
acteurs quelques comédiens rigolo et
puis en avant tout le monde autour de la
piscine et du barbecue et on fait le
film et on se pose pas de question les
gens ne veulent pas se poser de
questions alors du coup je pose la
question alors je peux comprendre à la
limite je sais pas si c'est encore
d'actualité aujourd'hui il ya 20 ans
mais aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée des
plateformes comme netflix amazon prime
ou ensemble que eux aussi cherchent
voilà des cinéastes
qui ont leur univers à eux je pense
notamment à jeûner qui est parti chez
netflix et qui a fait son film est ce
que c'est peut-être pas plus facile
aujourd'hui d'aller produire un pacte
des loups bis avec ces gens là non non
non non non non elle est plate forme au
départ ont un peu tâtonné enfin là je
donne vraiment ma vision des choses
elles ont un peu tâtonné pour savoir
qu'est ce que les gens et voudrait
exactement et elles se sont rendus assez
vite compte que en france par exemple il
faudrait produire plus tôt et milice
paris ce que produire que produire
quelque chose d'un peu plus
un peu plus
audacieux en tout cas des choses que les
anglo saxons on s'affaire bien où les
coréens par exemple il ya d'excellentes
séries coréennes sur netflix en
particulier de kingdom mais ça montre
bien que
voilà chacun chez soi chacun fait ton
truc le public français est habitué à
voir finalement des espèces de 2 voilà
deux de fiction qui ciblent généralement
des fictions de quartier quoi mais je
des choses qui se passent dans trois
pâtés de maisons avec des voisins
voilà où des ou des bobos et c'est ça
qu'on leur donne cette façon oui les
plateformes il ya eu un moment sa
poussette cette sensation que il allait
produire des choses différentes et puis
en fait maintenant et au contraire il
donne une image presque encore plus
caricaturale
de ce que chaque public que ça soit
cuite français ou public italien au
public américain ou public anglais veut
en fait et au contraire les accentue
encore plus le le rétrécissement sur
quel quelques schémas narratifs tout ça
je vois donc femme moi personnellement
je suis abonné à plusieurs plateformes
et je vois pas de
je vois pas particulièrement des oeuvres
audacieuses
c'est vrai c'est et ça fait un moment
maintenant qu'ils existent surtout avec
la pandémie et tout ça donc je
personnellement s'il devait faire des
choses audacieuses je pense que ça
aurait déjà été le cas mais on voit bien
que ce que c'est en train de devenir
voilà très très localisés
chiche